people who are cynical about religious
structures like to think of faith as the
willingness to demolish your intellect
in the service of superstition and you
know there's there's something to be
said for that perspective but not a lot
because the reality is much more
sophisticated part of the faith that's
that that is being insisted upon in the
Old Testament is something like and I'm
speaking psychologically here again that
it's useful to pause it a high high good
and to aim at it so and I really think
that's practically useful to the
research we've done with the Future
authoring program for example indicates
pretty clearly that if you get people to
conceptualize an ideal and a balanced
ideal you know so what do you want for
your family what do you want for your
career what do you want for your
education what do you want for your
character development how are you going
to use your time outside of work how are
you going to structure your use of drugs
and alcohol in places where you might
get impulsive how can you avoid falling
into a horrible pit if you really think
that through and you come up with an
integrated ideal and you you put it
above you as something to reach for
then you're more committed to the world
in a positive way and you're less
tormented by anxiety and uncertainty and
so and that makes sense right because
here you are alive and everything and so
unless you were capable if you're not
capable of manifesting some positive
relationship with the fact of your being
then how could that be anything other
than hellish because you it would just
be anxiety provoking and terrible
because you're vulnerable and there'd be
nothing useful or worthwhile to do well
that's just not I just can't see that as
a winning strategy for anyone you can
make a rational case for adopting that
strategy in that you know you can say
well there's no evidence for for a
transcendent morality or for an ultimate
meaning there's no hard empirical
evidence but it seems to me that there's
existential evidence as well that has to
be taken into account and of course
psychologists have talked about this a
lot Carl Rogers
for example in um-- for that matter
freud for that matter most of the great
psychologists have pointed out that you
know you can derive reasonable
information that's that's solid from
your own experience especially if you
also talk to other people and you can
kind of see in your own life when you're
on a productive path that sort of in
nobles and enlightens you or a
destructive path and i think it's kind
of useful to think that maybe the
dichotomy between those two paths might
be real you know and and because that
also allows you to give credence to your
intuitions about that sort of thing but
I don't anyways I don't think it's
unreasonable to posit that since you're
alive adopting the highest possible
regard for the fact that you're alive
and that you're surrounded by other
creatures that are alive I just can't
see how that can possibly be construed
as a losing strategy and so that's the
first thing so that's something like
faith right it's faith it's not it's not
only faith in your being but it's faith
in being as such and the faith would be
something like if you could orient your
being properly then maybe that would
orient you with being as such and you
never know like I mean it might be true
there's no reason to assume that it
wouldn't be true I mean even if you just
take a strict biological perspective on
this and think about us as the product
of three and a half billion years of
evolution I mean we have struggled over
all those billions of years to be alive
and to match ourselves with reality and
so because one of the things I've often
wondered is you know life is definitely
difficult there's no doubt about that
and that's unfair and there's inequality
and all of those things and people are
subject to all sorts of terrible things
but I also wonder if you weren't
actively striving to make things worse
just how much better could they be you
know because people are very they like
houses that are divided amongst
themselves they're pointing in six
different directions at the same time
they're working at cross-purposes to
themselves because of bitterness or
beacon and resentment and on what
unprocessed memories and childhood
hatreds and
unexamined assumptions all sorts of
things and you you just gotta wonder if
you could push that aside and or int
yourself properly and then the other
thing that of course is stressed very
heavily in the Old Testament and of
course that goes through the entire
biblical corpus is that it's not only
enough to establish a positive
relationship with being which I think is
the essential it's a good description of
faith you have to make that decision
right because being is very ambivalent
and you can make the case that maybe
it's something that should have never
happened but that doesn't seem to be
productive to me and faith seems to me
I'm going to act as if being is
ultimately justifiable and that if I
partake in it properly I will improve it
rather than making it worse so I think
that's the statement of faith and then
what seems to go along with that is
something like truth in conception and
action you know even people like Jacob
who are pretty damn morally ambivalent
to begin with get hammered a lot by what
they go through and what seems to happen
is that they're hammered into some sort
of ethical shape right so by the
midpoint of their life's journey there's
people who are solidly planted who you
can trust and who don't betray being or
themselves or their fellow man and so
it's an interesting I mean it seems
reasonable to me to first assume that
you have to establish a relationship
with something that's transcendent it
might even be just the future version of
you but and then second that you have to
align yourself with reality in a
truthful manner and that that's your
best bet and the biblical stories are
actually quite realistic about that too
because they don't really say that if
you do that you're going to be instantly
transported to the promised land
like even Moses as we'll find out in the
Exodus stories he never makes it to the
promised land and so it's not like
you're offered instantaneous final
Redemption if you move out forthrightly
into the world establish a faithful
relationship with being an attempt to
conduct yourself with integrity but it's
your best bet and it might be good
enough and even if it's not good enough
it's really preferable to the
alternative which seems to be something
closely akin to hell both personal and
social